- This is our moment.
- Now get out there
and tell the world
that women deserve
the right to vote.
(laughing)
- Sorry I thought you said vote.
- [Voice Over] Bathing
costume carriage wash.
- That is just indecent.
♪American we ain't
come that far♪
- It's a woman wearing pants.
- What'll they think of next?
Women's shoes?
Medicine but for women?
- I'm running for president.
- Bring back our jobs.
- You just have to believe
that you have them already.
(yelling)
(chanting)
- It's a bambino.
- Oh she's got a bomb.
- She's got a bomb.
(laughing)
♪same s#!% another period♪
(screaming)
- You look as though you
could use a hand blanch.
- It's very difficult
to shovel coal
while caring for a baby.
- Maybe you shouldn't
have had a baby.
- The goal is to make you
look as much like a corpse
as possible without
actually killing you.
- Down with the patriarchy.
- Idiot.
- Hey.
- Beatrice now are you a
regular slut or a nasty slut?
- Excuse my name's Lilliace.
♪same s#!% another period♪
- I can't believe
this happened to us.
- Well on the bright side
we'll never have to vote
or get a job so there's that.
♪You've come along way
America, yeah right♪
- We're opening our
own envelopes now?
What are we coal miners?